hello there this is uh steve let me just
uh get my sound on here
hello there this is steve
thelinguist.blogs.com
um i'm going to respond to a comment
that i had to my recent
video or webcast podcast about output
and stuart asked if i could talk a
little bit about
older learners
and
before i do that i'll answer irene for
talking about older learners irene and i
irina's in germany she is a german
speaker she's learning english
she and i are both over 60.
she of course is much younger than i am
although i've never met her
and
she asked me what kind of a microphone i
use i use
this thing it's called a snowball it's
my latest acquisition
and that way i can record
the
webcast and put up a sound file for
those people who download
in order to listen and improve their
english again i'm not going to do a
transcript if this bothers people they
can send me a note and maybe i will
transcribe some of them
um
edwin very helpfully suggested that i
could extract the sound file from
uh from youtube and i had a look and i
can't figure out how to do it and i'm
not about to try to learn
because i've invested in this snowball
now if edwin comes back very strongly
and says that it's much easier to do it
that way then i might just do it but for
the time being i'm going to rely on
snowball here so uh older learners first
of all what's old i mean stewart talks
about 30 and 40 years old
i'm over 60 as i said so is irene irene
has who's by the way has provided us
with great german language content for
link lingq.com
a very enthusiastic member of the link
community
uh you know
she has made tremendous progress in her
english in the last year or so
i feel that i've had made
significant progress in my
in my russian
over 60 i learned cantonese when i was
55
i've been working on languages
most of the languages that i learned
i was over 20
so um
yeah
i think that
there is this feeling that younger
children
under the age of five are better at
learning languages
i don't necessarily agree but but
younger children have certain advantages
number one they are not embarrassed they
are not concerned
they're not afraid to sound like
children when they speak because they
are children
um we uh people who are able to speak
very well in their own language are
reluctant to speak in a second language
because they feel that they
sound foolish they sound like children
they can't say what they want to say and
so forth so they have a lot of hang-ups
but
older learners bring with them all of
the knowledge the experience
the literacy they have
typically most often not always in their
own language uh i mean if now that i'm
learning russian i don't want to sound
like a five-year-old russian child or a
three-year-old russian child i want to
read tolstoy i want to read the daily
news i want eventually to be able to
discuss things as an adult
so um and and i will do that and i will
achieve it within two years
uh with an hour of study a day here and
there occasionally more
months of doing nothing
i will achieve it
um
child
you know
thrust in a situation where everyone
else is speaking another language
they'll learn that language very quickly
but they'll only learn it to the level
and to the vocabulary level of of
children of their age
so i think children there's two things
with children one is that they
obviously are less inhibited they're not
corrected they're not afraid to make
mistakes they're not afraid to
come across as a child because they are
a child
and the second thing is i believe that
probably although i'm not a
neuroscientist obviously but probably um
in the first five six seven years of
your life as the the you know the all
the neurons in your brain are are
charging around and competing for space
and trying to establish
uh room for different
functions and and and cognitive you know
capabilities
if you are um
put in a situation where you hear a
variety of languages that's a good thing
and i if i were doing language study in
schools i would not try and teach one
second language i would expose kids to
many languages a lot of listening and
reading forget the grammar and and open
their minds to the different sounds and
the different ways that there are of
saying things in different languages let
them listen to stories and all of that
is beneficial but i know people who were
exposed to a second language as children
and who did not end up being good
language learners i know people who did
not have that exposure and became good
language learners whatever your genetic
predisposition is
whatever the environment you grew up in
as a child is
you know your capability to learn
languages is what it is so forget about
it forget about it the question now is
what are you going to do
and i think there
the
the approach that i take i mean i'm an
adult i've learned most of my languages
as an adult
i think it's the one that works best for
adults in other words
first of all
understand
work with input
get to the point where you can
understand what is said you can
understand what is written
because
yeah adults don't want to be confronted
with a situation where they come across
as stupid where they're looking for
words and they can't find them where
they're in a class with 20 people and
they're all bumbling
in another language uh far better to
spend
six months
getting used to a language doing a lot
of listening to a lot of reading
accumulate vocabulary and then
as you're ready for it start
speaking so i think
i mean i recommend the same for both i
recommend the same for children the
children listen to stories i think
that there's not that much of a
difference i think the adult has
a number of advantages over the child in
everything except pronunciation i think
the child's mind is more flexible more
open to new sounds
uh the
the adult is more inhibited
uh is perhaps restricted by the sounds
the sound range that they've sort of
you know spent 20 30 40 years you know
getting used to
so the children will do better on
pronunciation typically
but other than that the adult knows more
concepts knows more vocabulary in their
own language has more experience
and all of this is relevant as they try
to associate what they know in their own
language to what they're trying to learn
in the new language adults are better
language learners
overall period there's no question i
mean if if i went to anyone and said
look in six months you've got you know
full time you go at it but if you
achieve a level where you can read the
newspaper and you can discuss
politics or art or history in this other
language if you do that i'll give you a
million dollars
adults are going to make it
and children wouldn't
three-year-olds would not achieve that
level
so um adults can be better language
learners they have some hang-ups
uh the best approach for adults is the
input approach in my opinion very
definitely
and avoid being put in a situation where
you're forced to produce the language uh
too early now as i said in my in my
little uh presentation on output yeah do
talk once or twice a week three times a
week whatever you're comfortable with
but don't think you're gonna talk your
way to fluency don't plan on spending
five hours a day talking spend most of
your time listening and reading and
accumulating vocabulary so really the
message for the adults is not very
different than what it is
for
children and now i put my glasses back
on and see if i can turn all this off
again
so where are we here
okay